see CBS News chief cars Washington
correspondent and Face the Nation anchor
John Dickerson is with us good morning
morning Charlie we'll turn to the
testimony of the Attorney General in a
moment but first this idea of firing
Muller
well it's interesting to hear Marco
Rubio because that's what matters it
matters that it would be it would be
obviously a huge deal if the president
did this but the question really then
comes back to the Congress and would
Republicans say this is going too far
because that's what matters is if the
president does something that starts to
leave to have people in his own party
lead him so far they haven't so far they
laughter last week's testimony they were
still supporting the president and
Foursquare behind him and when you turn
to the Attorney General and his
testimony what do you think is it was
important thing we might get from him
that will add to the Comey Trump
conflict well what we get from him we
may not get much problem from him
because on the Comey Trump area he will
likely say executive privilege and
basically my conversations to the
president about this and any area around
it are privileged the question then
would be what about his conversations
with Comey himself and that'll be
interesting in other words James Comey
has served a lot of things about what
the Attorney General did or didn't do
and the Attorney General could stand up
for himself order and that that area
might we might actually get some
information
he's a former colleague how do you think
he'll be treated today well that'll be
interesting to watch and there was a lot
of deference given to James Comey from
Republicans and Democrats last week some
members of the committee see themselves
in bright lights and see a potential you
know start turned for them so how they
treat him will be a chance for them to
burnish their own sense of themselves
but he's a former colleague and usually
there's some deference that's offered to
a former colleague so that'll be an
interesting piece of theater to watch
we saw what can clearly be described as
an unusual cabinet meeting yesterday
with each of his secretaries praising
him saying it's an honor and a blessing
to serve etc who organized it this way
and why did they do this
well it was an extraordinary bath of
adulation I I'm not sure what the
organizing principle was it was clearly
a public relations effort to bolster the
presidency what's interesting is I mean
not only imagine if that were used to
talk about the agenda for the Forgotten
man
and ran on to talk about the opioid
crisis to talk about things that were
being done for the people that elected
him as opposed to just merely offering
praise after praise well in fact the
president himself said never has there
been a president with few exceptions
who's passed more legislation who's done
more things that's just not true
there isn't a major piece of legislation
that's been passed he well there are the
pieces of legislation to the extent the
big ones that have passed are ones that
basically were passed through the
Congressional review act which is
basically something that they had
pre-loaded before this presidency so on
his big agenda items they have not come
through and that's right this is a
another claim that bares some challenge
John Dickerson thank you Charlie